[Music]
Ford in Wisconsin says is it better to
take out loans to get through school
fast and start making money or go
through slower working and paying as I
go none of the above work more and go
through fast I worked 40 to 60 hours a
week when I was in college and I got
through in four years my GPA doesn't
matter because you all listen to me
anyway it was a 2.97 I'm still pissed
about the three 100's of a point but
anyway I not GPA suffered I could have
been I mean I have the intellect to be a
4.0 student but I worked all the time
and still got through my net worth was a
dollar 66 when I graduated work all the
time go to an inexpensive school that
you can afford and go through fast so I
don't buy these false premises when you
set up these false logic between two
things that don't have to be I either
take out loans or I go through really
slowly how about none of the above
that's my answer
a sea-doo a multiple question you'll
take these tests when you're in college
they're multiple multiple choice
questions and see none of the above work
like a maniac and listen I it's
wonderful if you can have a social
experience while you're in college the
college experience that's wonderful I
don't mind you having them I'm not mad
at it but the idea that you finance that
it's absolutely freaking ludicrous it's
nuts